different avenues We discussed
his etiquettes in salah. We
discussed his etiquettes in
Udu. Discussed his etiquettes
in fasting. In We discussed his
etiquettes in eating.
And now we have gone on to the
chapters regarding the prophet
etiquette. And assalam.
Conveying a salaam. Important
that we have kind of an
introduction to this issue
Something that needs to be
said. and that is that a Salem
conveying a salam, saying
assalamu alaikum. actually a
very serious thing. It's
something that's been given a
lot of attention by Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala says
[Silence]
Indeed Allah is going to
recompense and judge a person
over everything. So, he ends
the verse here by saying in the
Hashiba.
That Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala judges and calculates
and judgement every single
thing that a person does.
Meaning that even this that we
say
is a major thing because this
is the of Islam. And not only
that but it is the Tahiya, the
salutations of Adam Alaihi
Salam that he was taught by the
angels. We mentioned the
narration in Bukhari and
Muslim. That's when Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala created
Adam writes
Rasulullah and
[Silence]
to them to say assalamu alaikum
and he said, listen to what
they salute you with because
what they respond to you with
is going to be your salutations
and the salutations of your
offspring after you. And so, he
went to them and he said,
assalamu alaikum. And they said
to him. Assalamu alaikum.
Now, this is the salutations of
the Muslims and it's the
salutations of the prophets and
messengers. We need to discuss
a couple of things. Number one,
When we say
What does this mean? What's the
meaning of assalamu alaikum?
Assalamu alaikum. The prophet
tells us the meaning of it. In
a narration collected by Al
Bukhari Rahima Allah. and
[Silence]
evil or any hardship or any. He
provides that protection as
well to the believers. So, when
a person says it is essentially
saying, may Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala protect you
from any misfortune from any
harm as he is a Salem.
Subhanahu wa ta'ala.
Likewise,
also means that may protection
and peace be upon you all. and
this articulates something.
What does it articulate? It
articulates goodwill and it
articulates safety from the
person who says assalam. So
when you approach a people and
you say assalamu alaikum. You
are essentially announcing to
them that you are not a threat
to them and they are safe in
your company. That's what
you're saying.
So, it's kind of
counterintuitive if a person
starts with and then goes on to
harm the same people that they
saluted with a salaam And so,
when a person says, we initiate
our contact with one another as
Muslims based on this, based on
safety, based on safety, when a
person says they're essentially
saying, you are safe in my
presence and you're and, and
you're safe, in your absence.
With me. And when they say they
are responding to that. and so,
this is something that we have
to be mindful of when we say it
because a lot of the things
that we say because we say it
so much and it's kind of
there's not a lot of thought
behind it, right? if you
say to someone, Giusec, you
know, these are good things to
say but a lot of us say it's
just as a kind of filler in our
statements but these are
actually duas. These are
prayers for a person. So, when
we make that prayer for a
person. If I say
I have in my intention that I'm
making dua for this person.
Right? So these things are not
to be misused. The prophet
tells us that a Salam is
something that is instrumental
in spreading good will and love
between the Muslim
us. He says in the narration of
Muslim
[Silence]
other. It will sprout love
between you all, convey a salam
to one another. and so
is not only something that is a
salutation and an articulation
of good will but it's also the
basis of our dealings with each
other. Johnny notice how Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala
made the legislation and
prescribed conveying a Sadam
between each other. Notice how
it's set. That we convey a
salaam when we initiate contact
with each other. And that we
also convey a salaam when we
break contact with each other.
So when we enter each other's
presence we say when we leave
each other's presence we say
assalamu alaikum. Alright? He
this narration. The narration
is in
[Silence]
is not more important than the
last. Meaning, saying a salaam
when you approach and initiate
contact is not more important
than when you leave each
other's presence. Meaning that
they are both equal in their
significance. Just imagine with
me and and it's very true.
Attack up.
Assalamu alaikum.
[Silence]
right? If a Muslim approaches
you. Good morning. how are you?
you know, says all the
pleasant things. Good
afternoon. anything pleasant
to initiate with you is you'll
never take the place of You
will leave that person's
presence feeling what? Feeling
that the interaction was
deficient For this reason, the
prophet
[Silence]
He said, the Jews speaking
about the Jews of Madinah to
the
[Silence]
and so because of the
importance of lamb. There's a
lot of rulings in the Quran, in
the Sunnah, regarding a Salem,
how to give it, how to respond,
when to say assalam, how
frequently, etcetera, etcetera.
The prophet and his companions
took a salaam so seriously that
they would convey to one
another even if they split up
to go around the tree.
[Silence]
This is because they would take
every opportunity possible to
say assalamu alaikum to each
other.
Likewise, in an academic Yani,
Judea, to Salam, Bena, Sahaba,
[Silence]
However, if I have coworkers
most of them are work with me.
Every time I pass by their
desk, I'm going to shake their
hand, right? Every time we
pass, they shake their hand. If
you just saw me right now. Take
in the hand is something that
that is frequent than a Salem
but a Salem is something
constant. The companions took
it very seriously. They took
every opportunity they could to
convey a salaam to one another
because they understood the
importance of and the
uniqueness of a salam. It's
unique. It's unique to the
Muslims. And it's only for the
Muslims. The prophet said in
Bukhari a Muslim.
Salam. He said, do not initiate
a salaam to the Jews and the
Christians. Meaning, idolaters
and those who are. further away
in their diversion from Islam.
I mean, it's something only for
Muslims to initiate Islam. You
say to someone, that is only
for the Muslims. And we will
get into the etiquettes of that
inshallah. But it's very
important that we understand
the seriousness of a Salem. A
Salam is a very serious Shahira
of Islam.
I know that you all have felt
this way before That have you
ever met someone who's Muslim,
you think they're Muslim? Maybe
they're Arab, maybe they're
from your country. And they
approach you, maybe in public
somewhere, and they don't say
Assalam. And they speak with
you and so, you feel in
yourself something is off
about this person. It doesn't
feel this person is
Correct? We all have that
feeling. Says, what's up with
this guy? How about It's like
they're not full-blown Muslim
or something. It doesn't mean
that that's the case but that's
the feeling that a person has.
Right? So, a salaam is very
important. It's to be taken
very seriously. This is why we
never play around with the
wording of a Salem. And if you
bow the nest,
okay?
[Silence]
general the most
influential prophet upon our
legislation after the prophet
Muhammad is which prophet?
Ibrahim Alaihi Salam. Why?
Ibrahim.
most influential prophet of all
the prophets upon our religion
after the prophet Muhammad is
Ibrahim.
tells the prophet
we have articulated to you in
revelation, follow the religion
way of Ibrahim. So,
essentially, anything that we
hear about in the Quran, in the
Sunnah, about Ibrahim, if it
doesn't contradict the ruling
an hour in the words of the
prophet Muhammad in the Quran,
it's considered to be part of
his sunnah. In general.
So, the point is, is that a
Salam is very serious thing.
and hence, there are many
etiquettes regarding a setup.
how to initiate it, who should
initiate it, how to respond,
etcetera. initiating a salaam
in the opinion of the majority
of the scholarship of Islam is
it is preferable.
and responding to a salaam is
obligatory. It's obligatory
because Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala commands it in the
Quran, right? So, it is
preferable to initiate a Sadam,
obligatory to respond
should initiate the other with
a
prophet goes into these
details. He says
[Silence]
The one who is writing should
initiate the one who is walking
with and the smaller group
should initiate the bigger
group with Assalam.
And then the prophet added and
the one who is passing by the
one who is standing still. So,
we understand that essentially,
the one who has
the the person who is the the
etiquettes of Assalam should be
as follows. The young should
initiate the elder.
Passing should initiate the
standing
the walkin
g or standing should
initiate to the person who is
sitting. The one who is riding
should initiate the one who is
who is walking. And the smaller
group should initiate the
larger group. Right? And most
of the time, we see this in
people's actions. Even if they
don't know this narration, the
customs of the Muslims have to
add the
Now, what about what we see a
lot of people do and that is
instead of a salaam, hand.
[Silence]
Rather, if a person gestures
with his hand, it should be
because it's not proper or it's
not possible to say a sadam.
Verbally, loud to make them
hear. Someone's far away. You
don't have to scream at them.
If someone's behind glass or if
you're driving by in a car,
right? The prophet did this
He mentions that a group of
women, sisters were sitting the
masjid, and the prophet passed
by them, encountered them, and
he set a salaam to them and in
another wording of this
narration, he gestured with his
hand He says, the hand gesture
should always accompany a
salam, be accompanied by a
salam. You know, if I gesture
with my hand, I should also say
verbally. Just loud enough for
myself to hear. Right?
Likewise, the movement of the
head this, or whatever
people do. This is something
that the companions frowned
upon. And they mentioned that
this is the way that the people
of the book convey salutations
to each other, not Muslims,
right?
We mentioned that when a person
initiates contact
that the individual starts with
the
Likewise, if a person breaks
contact leaves the gathering or
what have you, they leave with
a Salem. Now, if a person
wishes to say something else
along with a Salem. So, for
instance, a person wants to say
good morning, good afternoon,
do they have to start with a
salaam or can they start with
something else? The of the
prophet the mass majority of
his sunnah is that he would
begin with a salam. However,
hadith and
had
[Silence]
And then you rejoin then you
should initiate a salaam once
again.